yeah yeah I'm mad one thing's for sure
I'm mad one thing's for sure
I'm mad what this for sure I am mad
because I called the back TV the other
day and they said they'd become my
Thursday and they also told me that they
would give me a confirmation text within
an hour telling me that they were
thoughtful from 12 to 4 but the next day
I didn't get a confirmation text and
then right after that I'll call them up
you know it because I'm a man of my word
and I want to make sure they are awful
and if they worried that I will be extra
mad but I couldn't see couldn't wait to
be so [ __ ] mad enough but even more
so I wanted the appointments happen so
after that I rang up I said I didn't get
a text and then the new lady said I
would get one within 24 hours when
somebody first guys say I will get it in
an hour she said she didn't know because
she was a different person now she would
definitely be better if it was the same
person but it wasn't so much for him you
better hurry
even though wanted to get mad at her it
wasn't her fault it still should
technically be her fault yeah so then I
hung up she said Thursday was a go but
then after that
I can't get a [ __ ] email even a day
later
why the [ __ ] are they [ __ ] with me
and so then the next day I called him
and they said oh we was so sorry
the day hands dude is that they hates me
say [ __ ] like this the whole time all we
really value is your customer I mean
definitely this day when I struck my
size stop like that I just want a guy to
[ __ ] me come on Thursday so then he
promised me today we have and I said
when can I have a confirmation email and
he told me ASAP because he wasn't in a
position to tell me exactly when the
email was gonna come yeah this was two
days to go I'm firing off tweets I'm
getting really bad because day not
responded finally I get is the air from
DIRECTV and they told me to tell me that
problem go
I already told four people two goddamn
problem and that [ __ ] made me so mad so
I just [ __ ] fired off a couple of
tweets right and I go to dish or Hulu a
[ __ ] just keep Netflix and keep his
Rayman but instead a guy called me
directly immediately right after that
from an 800 number then I picked up I
didn't understand the words the guys
that except for that the people will
definitely go through Thursday I said I
don't have a [ __ ] email